[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kisses
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts are brilliant
expert guests this week is a head of
education that the Institute of Economic
Affairs dr. Steven Davis welcome to
trigonometry that's me yeah thank you
thank you for coming and what a time to
be here because exciting things are
happening in British politics and you've
been talking about this for a long time
and before we get into that just tell us
a little bit about who you are what's
been your journey through life so I us
and our viewers know well to start at
the beginning I suppose I was born in
Scotland in a place called Grangemouth
went to university in Scotland at st.
Andrews
I'm historian by training although I
talk a lot about economics these days my
family roots are all in Manchester and
East Lancashire Burnley to be precise
and Newton Heath and Manchester lived in
Manchester since 1979 stormed City fan I
usually work at the Manchester
Metropolitan University Manchester
Polytechnic as it was before then but a
few years ago I kicked the world of
academia into touch and I went full-time
into the think-tank world which I had
been involved with for quite a long time
actually and I worked first for a
think-tank in the United States called
the Institute for Humane studies and
then at the Institute of Economic
Affairs for the last nine to ten years
or so and I do other kinds of freelance
work as well so that's where I am at the
moment really looking forward to City
winning the title and denying Liverpool
the title again and also you know taking
a great interest in what's going on in
the world right now well you've managed
to trigger a big portion of our
following already with those comments
fantastic called trigonometry for a
reason but it's it's so great to have
you here because as I said we're
recording this this video come out about
a week or so from now
but so far you you've been talking about
a realignment of politics for a long
time and as we discussed before the
showed not everyone was immediately kind
of receptive to that idea but you've
been talking about it for five or six
years and it's actually happening I
think as as we speak 11 MPs have left
their mainstream parties 8 Labour 3
conservative to create this independent
group yeah
so take us back to the beginning what is
this all about well there's you need to
distinguish between the factional moves
in Parliament which are fascinating and
interesting but and on the one hand and
beelined that the underlying structural
changes in politics which is what I mean
by realignment now the way to understand
that is this at most times lots of
people have disagreed for all kinds of
things but what we don't ever do in any
country is elect lots of individual
politicians who then form shifting ad
hoc coalition's around each particular
issue as it arises what you find instead
is that there's always one issue or
maybe two which are the aligning issue
people group into large political bloc's
or tribes depending on the view that
they have of that one big issue now that
tribe it agrees on one side of that big
issue will probably have lots of
internal disagreements about other
issues but that's not that doesn't
matter because politics is aligned
around the one big issue so for the last
4050 years or so the two big issues have
been on the one hand whether or not you
favor free markets or state control of
the economy and on the other hand
whether or not you think that the state
has a role to play in enforcing moral
rules so with that second issue at one
end of the pole you could be John Stuart
Mill you think people should be allowed
to do whatever they like but brilliant
almost no limits at the other end you
could be well you could be like a formal
guest of yours PC Hitchens who thinks
that you know the state should be doing
all kinds of things to stop people you
know taking cannabis and there's all the
kinds of things Peter doesn't approve of
so when you put those two words and
getting that dig in whether you put
those two axes together you end up with
four broad blocks of voters and the
split which for the
thirty forty years has been between one
group who are pro market but socially
conservative like us Republicans for
example and another group who are not
exactly anti market but pro-government
intervention in the economy but socially
liberal like us Democrats for example
that's been the split now my argument is
that while the economic division is
still there the other division has
changed we're seeing a new division
appearing in politics and the division
here is between nationalists and
globalists basically it's between people
who think that the nation-state is a
vital political institution and who
favor traditional national identity as
opposed to people who think that
national identity is only one part of
what you are not necessarily the most
important thing and that you need to
move towards a world of more open
borders freer trade for your movement
more supranational forms of government
like the EU perhaps and that's the
emerging division I think in most
countries the problem we have in Britain
and indeed many other countries is that
our two big parties don't match up to
that new division the division between
globalist and nationalists splits both
of the two parties down the middle and
so what is happening is that in fact
that real division out there in the
public is now not yet reflected by the
parties but the parties are reorganizing
themselves if you will to get more in
line with this newly merging division
that's what I mean by realignment and
one of the things you've talked about
before you jump in Francis is that this
is just the beginning yes what's
happening in party political terms
within Britain is just the beginning so
you've been predicting things for a
while you maybe didn't get as much
credit as you deserve how about you you
use this opportunity to make a bunch of
other predictions that you don't then go
look look I was right okay I think what
is going to happen is this first of all
the distractions we've seen to this
independent group we're only the start
of a process quite a lot more Labour MPs
and a few more Conservative MPs are
going to defect this has probably been
an arrangement set up in advance and I
imagine that what you're going to see is
a steady stream of defections this is
being done for media management purpose
is to keep the story in headlines over
time that's how it's actually organized
you sound politicians are behaving
cynically oh yes unfortunately so so
that's what it's going to happen now
the the context for all these splits in
Parliament at the moment is that we
can't have a general election because
the fixed term Parliament act which
means that you need two-thirds of MPs to
vote for a general election and there's
always going to be at least a third of
Parliament at the moment who don't want
a general election for the good reason
that they fear they'll lose their seats
so there isn't going to be a majority
for dissolving Parliament's at the
moment plus you could do it with a
no-confidence vote but as recent events
have shown even if the government has
lost its majority there's still a
majority you think that they do not want
Jeremy Corbyn to be Prime Minister and
so she's not going to lose a confidence
vote so we aren't gonna have a general
election at the same time we have a hard
legal deadline for leaving the EU on the
29th of March and that basically means
that Parliament has become a pressure
cooker and all the divisions within the
parties are becoming more and more
intense and it's leading both of the
parties to fracture and the emergence of
quite distinct groups in Parliament
which I think will become the
parliamentary wings or of two new
parties effectively certainly one new
party maybe two because it's interesting
you're talking about all of this and but
there is a party out there that is
broadly centrist profane joining the Lib
Dems that's that's a very good question
and I think it's partly because they
still haven't gotten over the for them
near-fatal experience of being in
coalition with the Conservatives they
should have learned from history
whenever the Labour Party the Liberal
Party rather has historically gone into
coalition or supported one of the other
two parties it's been the kiss of death
and I think they still haven't gotten
over that plus they have the problem
that they have a number of outstanding
MPs but nobody who's in a really
prominent leadership role who takes that
box of really appealing to a wide part
of the public they don't have any
left her still comfortable with gay sex
yes so how big is this independent group
going to be two or three months from and
using I think it could be about 40 to 50
members of parliament mmm I would not be
surprised so it may be I would say we're
probably going to see about another 20
Labour MPs leave and another nine or so
conservative MPs so several Latour emps
like Nick Bowles have said that they're
basically waiting to see how votes go on
various practices amendments in
Parliament but I think that's pretty
much certainly he's dead I'm gonna wake
of the way he wants to them to and
therefore he's going to leave and I
think this is true of quite a number of
other MPs what what would the breaks at
play in this was it the catalyst or was
this always going to happen I think that
this realignment was always going to
happen but brexit was the catalyst and
the lit that's a very good analogy
because in chemistry a catalyst is a
substance that speeds up a reaction but
isn't actually involved in the reaction
and that's exactly what brexit has done
its made the realignment of British
politics around nationalism versus
cosmopolitanism happened much more
quickly than otherwise would have done
and brexit and how you feel about leave
or remain is a kind of proxy for a whole
lot of other issues issues and feelings
about identity a very revealing poll
you'll find this entertaining perhaps
about levers and remainders was to ask
them what their favorite brands were and
the favorite levers brands were things
like Hovis Bisto HP sauce Heinz baked
beans a whole list of quintessentially
1950s traditional British brands the
favourite brands have remained voters
were things like uber Apple iMac a whole
range of very dujour modish trendy
brands that tells you a huge amount
which is that the division between
remain and leave is actually just the
expression of a much deeper if you like
cultural divide which is partly a
division between old and young part
between north and Midlands and the south
partly between professional and
university educators and traditional
working class or middle class a whole
series of social and
hopeful divisions like that it's you
talk about the divisions I always try
and think how are we gonna heal these
divisions well that's what politics is
about realignments of this kind take
place every 40 years or so so we had one
in the 1880s 1885 to 1893 we had one in
the 1920s 20 1922 to 31 we had one in
the 1970s and early 80's
each time you have a realignment
initially politics is very very bitter
that's because the new issue is one that
people have it's fresh
people are very divided by it there
isn't much center ground but what the
democratic political process does is
over time over 10 20 years or so the
sort of business and starkness of that
division is ameliorated and actually you
do get the emergence of a center I'm
actually quite excited as someone who's
horrified by the extremes on both sides
which seem to be to have kind of got
hold of the microphone recently and
there they are the ones that are getting
all the attention both on the left and
on the right I'm quite excited about the
idea that you have a new centrist force
emerging on the one hand on the other
hand I look at these the people who are
forming this group and it seems to me
like the number one driving force behind
them their motivation in terms of
creating this is really these are people
who are vehemently opposed to brexit
that's what's forced them to leave their
parties and as we were talking just
before we started that's not necessarily
a very centrist now point of view so so
it's a party that's allegedly in the
sense of or it's a group for now that's
allegedly in the center but it's not
actually the thing is this when you have
a political realignment what happens is
that the center is redefined because
when you have a stable alignment when
everybody knows that the big dividing
issue is one particular question you
know where you stand on that issue and
there's going to be a lot of people who
are in the middle of that issue so in
the famed plastic one of state control
of the economy versus free markets you
had radical they say fair free market is
in the one hand you had people that
Jeremy Corbyn old-fashioned socialist on
the other end and then in between there
was a middle now when the alignment
changes when the
issue that politics is aligned around
becomes a different one what you find is
that the center is redefined and people
who were in the center on the old issue
may not be in the center on the new one
now the people your if the new aligning
issue as I argue is internationalism
versus nationalism then people like
chopper Ramona and it's uber II and all
the others who left form this
independent group they're actually
pretty far out from one extreme of that
new alignment so actually it's a mistake
to think of them as centrist the center
what it is to be in the center is being
redefined on the other hand by the way
that means that you should not feel that
the center has collapsed which is a kind
of common perspective I think you've
just articulated that's not what's going
on what's happening is that what it is
to be in the center has a different
content now to what it did before
to be in the center used to mean that
you favored a moderate degree of state
intervention but a broadly with a baby
quite big welfare state but a broadly
market economy Tony Blair basically what
without the wars yes all that stuff
let's draw a veil away but the what
being in the center was going to be in
the cup of years time is that you favor
a certain amount of immigration control
but you're not a hard-line nativist
nationalist you are broadly in favor of
international cooperation but you don't
want the kind of complete merging of
sovereignty that the EU meets that's
what the new center is going to be
essentially so the you're still allowed
you start up a center position but the
content of that position is determined
by what the underlying alignment is and
as I say this new party is basically the
globalist internationalist party the
things they haven't quite got the header
on that the other problem is that I'm
afraid to say quite a lot of them typify
another phenomenal in the last twenty
years which is the professional
political class not all of them but
quite a lot of them too and the British
public policy is totally fed up with
mass produced manicured politicians of
the kind of Peter Mandelson has left as
is it legacy got helping and that that
sword that's one reason why Jeremy
Corbyn is popular he doesn't think that
kind of Sarah
nor does Jacob Riis Morgan
Viraj exactly these are that's why the
public is at the moment in the market
for politicians who have seem to be
their own man or woman and not a kind of
identikit done PPP at Oxford and you
know gone to the right schools and got
the kind of identical set of views
politicians so they need to find some
way of giving themselves a distinctive
identity but I think that will actually
happen because as I say what's going on
in Parliament is only the kind of froth
on the top of a much more profound
social shift but it's also quite
regressive when you think about it like
you said because the reality is we voted
for broke so we have to we have to leave
so by actually it's choosing to go this
particular route on you just denying a
reality well not necessarily the I think
as long as these people insist that they
want a second vote they are denying
reality and I think that's an extremely
dangerous road to go down I believe we
were to have a second referendum the
political consensus could consequences
would be disastrous that would give the
biggest boost ever to people like Tommy
Robinson and other political pond life
and the the far-right if you want to
call it that I think it'll be really a
really big mistake and as you say the
public was asked to vote in this issue
they were told the results of the issue
would be enacted by Parliament so to say
well sorry you've got it wrong let's you
know have another try would be
incredibly offensive what I think this
group is moving towards though and I
think we'll be forced to move towards is
the position that okay we're going to
leave we deeply regret it and we're
going to campaign that we should rejoin
and write joy I think that's what
they're possibly I I do not see a wide
public support for Reid oh you'd be
surprised I really I think there is
there to go back to pointing right
earlier there was a poll done recently
which showed that people's attachment to
their party loyal identity as
conservative voters labour votes as
whatever was very very weak less than 20
less than 30 percent felt a strong
identification with the party over 75
percent felt a very powerful
identification with their statuses leave
or remain voters and I think you
underestimate the degree to which
there's a very powerful cancer
two unreconciled remain errs out there
in the country about 25% roughly I would
say of the voters and that's basically
the constituency that this new party
that's emerging the moment is going to
appeal to but do you don't think that's
kind of like polling boxes in the middle
of a boxing match like yeah I hate him
but once the fires over they're all
hugging and whatever like once we
practice it happens people will be
reconciled to the fact that happened I
well some people will be but I think
that there are going to be like I say
about twenty five percent of the voters
twenty-five to thirty percent who are
utterly unreconciled and the the these
are the people who have a genuine strong
ideological commitment if you like to
the European project there aren't enough
of them to win the referendum which is
why there wasn't a positive pro-eu case
made during the referendum that's why
instead we got this ridiculous current
project fear nonsense from George
Osborne and others about how the sky was
going to fall any we voted to leave but
that is a significant bloc of voters and
the other thing about me is they're
geographically concentrated that 25 to
30 percent of unreconciled remainders
have a distinct social profile they're
typically younger more educated
middle-class professionals and they live
overwhelmingly in London the southeast
and middle-class enclaves like Wilmslow
or thought to be outside London so a
place like Oxford as well in Cambridge
so that they have a that means that the
political prospects for a new party was
kind of actually better than people
might imagine the big problem the SDP
had historically for example was that
each vote was very evenly spread around
the country which in our electoral
system gets you absolutely nowhere
whereas this party I think will have a
much more concentrated vote like an SNP
like impact that's quite possible yes I
think so but they're never realistically
going to get into power well what is
likely to happen is that we will see
over the next couple of years some
pretty confused politics like we did in
the early part of the 1920s for example
I think it's quite likely we'll have
hung Parliament's now we may have
changing the electoral system that's
that's a possibility the main reason why
we stick with first-past-the-post is
because it yields decisive results if it
stops doing that the case for changing
the system becomes quite strong on the
other hand it could well be that
actually what will happen is after a few
rather confusing elections we'll end up
with two large parties and this
breakaway faction will either become the
core of one of them or it will transform
one of the three existing parties in a
way that makes it into a party rather
like the one that they want to have I
think the first is actually more likely
in the second do you think part of the
problem as well is there there it
doesn't seem to be a political party out
there that represents the working class
so you talk to a lot of world working
class people and they say labour doesn't
represent me anymore which is a very
dangerous place to be politically
because that's when somebody you know at
the far-right sore whatever type of
people can swoop in and appeal directly
to that electorate which is the majority
I couldn't agree more
if you look all across Europe Social
Democratic parties are in really really
big trouble the Dutch Labour Party for
example which is one of the dominant
parties in Dutch politics from the 1900s
onwards at the last election in the
Netherlands they only got about five
percent of the vote a catastrophic
collapse the French Socialist Party is
basically completely imploded it hardly
exists anymore and the reason is that
Social Democratic left-wing parties all
over Europe now find that they are
trying to appeal to two different kinds
of voters traditional working-class
voters their traditional court base and
on the other hand the kind of people I
was talking about young green minded
environmentally conscious University
graduates who are interested in a
totally different agenda an agenda about
what you might call left-wing identity
politics super nationalism
cosmopolitanism now those two blocks of
voters agree about economics but they
don't agree about anything else and the
whole cultural politics of the kind of
middle class post 1968 New Left alienate
those working-class voters massively and
the danger as we can see say in Germany
is that they're the SPD's working-class
voters a lot of them have switched to
the far-right afd party and that's the
risk that could happen here it could
have happened with UKIP except that you
kick know basically imploded and went up
its own fundament partly cuz he was full
of you know complete cranks and not jobs
most sort of plot not speedin to be
blunt about it but
you're right if there's a block about 30
to 35% of the population
traditional working-class communities in
small towns parts the Midlands the north
of England who feel not only that
they're not being represented excuse me
but that they're being condescended to
talk down to and despise my educated
middle class elites in their own party
things could get really unpleasant well
that's what's been happening is what
you're talking about which is you know a
labourer from Hull being talked down to
but some vegan Corbin Easter it's not
gonna that's not gonna go down well at
all people will put up with a lot but
being patronized is something that
really annoys most people dead they're
just not going to take it so if you were
Jeremy Corbyn but if you were a Labour
leader how would you try and unite these
two tribes or is it simply impossible I
think it's very difficult almost
impossible actually what you would have
to do is to really bang on all the time
about economics because that's the one
subject of those two blocks approaches
agree upon and what you would have to do
is seriously downplay the cultural
leftism the identity politics the anti
imperialism which these into
anti-semitism in the current case in the
Labor Party the sort of obsession with
quite radical identity politics around
you know things like gay rights and so
on not there's anything wrong with that
but the point is you shouldn't make that
the all your major theme you should
instead emphasise working-class
self-interest and traditional very
traditional left-of-centre economics
more marks and less post-modernism if
you will that's what you would need to
do to try and keep those two blocks of
voters on board I do think that it's
very very difficult I have quite a lot
of sympathy for Jeremy Corbyn he's got a
very difficult job and obviously the
schism or the crack in between those two
blocks is breaks it because as we all
know how absolutely a lot of white
working-class voters voted bricks it and
the other side of them demonize them is
racist and for doing precisely and if
you look at they that's the example of
the cultural split I mentioned earlier
and if you look at the read papers like
The Guardian the in house papers were
remain
what they old constantly gone about is
how 60 to 70% of Labor voters voted
remain well that is true but the problem
is those the 30% who voted leave are
overwhelmingly Labour's traditional
working-class vote and they're
geographically very concentrated in
small towns the north on the Midlands
which is why a majority of labour seeds
vote II leave often by massive margins
you know you're talking about 70 to 80
percent leave votes in place like
Sunderland South parts of South
Yorkshire parts of the West Midlands so
the fact that you've got a ton of labour
voters mostly living in safe Tory seats
who voted remain it's not gonna help you
win the general election if you're
identified as being the pro remain party
when all the great majority of your
voters in actual labour seeds are
strongly leave and that's where there's
this huge cultural split as you say
right down the middle of that existing
labor coalition and I think trying to
hold it together is almost certainly
going to be you know impossible just as
an aside as well actually I think even
that is under estimating the case
because a lot of those traditional
labour voters they stopped voting
several elections so when they've come
back into the system to vote in the
referendum by that point they weren't
really labour voters anymore but
actually they are that base that you
talked about yeah so let's let's talk
about identity politics in the direction
that's going what do you make of that
well I think at the moment what you're
seeing is a big division between - this
is part of the new alignment there's a
big division between two different ways
of conceiving of identity one way has it
that your identity is largely something
that's given to you you don't really
choose to be what you are it's
determined by things like who your
parents are where you're born where you
live where you grow up a whole number of
factors that ultimately you don't
control the contrary view is that your
identity should as far as possible be
self-made that you should it should be
what you have chosen to be now you can
see this most clearly in sexual identity
that that's a kind of key point issue
here we're on the one hand you have
people who say well basically there's a
kind of biological fact that you have no
control over that your
man or a woman that said you have a
sexual orientation that's it on the
other hand there are people who say well
no actually because of modern technology
and for other reasons this is actually a
matter of choice you choose to define
what your sexual identity is what kind
of a person you are what you are and
that's the division it's a division
between two different ways of conceiving
or structuring your identity that also
plays into arguments about national
identity because one view would have it
that well you are born in a particular
part of the world you are brought up
within a particular national culture and
tradition and therefore you have a kind
of identity which you haven't chosen and
which you're a part which is part of you
and which it's important for you that is
it's maintained and it's upheld
otherwise the world is going to become a
rather strange threatening place for you
the contrary view is that no you're
living in a world of eztravel of
globally interconnected cities which are
world economy which has no long supply
chains that go halfway around the world
to produce everyday products and in that
world you basically can choose to live
way won't be the kind of person you want
and you can also to a great degree
construct a kind of whole set of
overlapping identities for yourself by
almost picking and choosing between
different cultural traditions those are
two radically different ways of
understanding what social identity is
and I think that's what the big division
is and that also ties into breaks it
breaks
absolutely where do you see yourself as
UK and where do you see yourself as
European yeah the question I really
wanted to ask is is this the end of the
Labour Party as we know it I think in
some senses when Jeremy Corbyn won that
election as I said it at sort of
immediate aftermath of that it the
Labour Party had been transformed it was
a new party at that point so what often
happens actually in British politics is
that you have a party with the same name
but it's completely different from what
that party was 10 years before it's like
the famous problem of triggers broom no
10 new handles for new heads but still
the same brain so in the same way if you
think about historically if you give a
historical example the Conservative
Party by the end of the 1920
was a completely different kind of party
in terms of the people who are in it the
people who voted for it
taught it had been before the First
World War it had changed basically from
being an aristocratic party to being a
business party you've got to put it that
way so I think what happened with with
the Labour Party is that it was a shell
party under the Blair Blair and brown
the party's membership had shrunk
dramatically there was almost nothing
left and then all these thousands of
Corbin East has joined the party with
great enthusiasm and essentially it
became a new party now the question is
what kind of party is that and I think
the issue which is what we were rooting
to a moment ago is is it going to
continue being a traditional
working-class party or will it become a
party of the radical populist left like
say podemos in Spain or maybe the Greens
in Germany certifier is hearing in
Greece that kind of that kind of thing I
would have to say that that's an open
question because the other factor and
this is the trade unions who are still
of course enormously powerful
institutions in the labour party and
obviously they represent the traditional
working-class aspect of it
however the leadership of the trade
unions has moved a long way away from
those organizations traditional
working-class roots so at the moment I
we all probably have a party called the
Labour Party around but I suspect he's
going to be less and less of a working
class party now in that case to go back
to the point you raised earlier what
kind of political force is then going to
be able to articulate working-class
interests and identity and concerns and
that could have a rather bad answer if
we're not careful so they Tommy Robinson
it's a very rich scene for him to plant
if if things don't work out yes
fortunately people like him are still
largely not taken serious or discredited
because of their association with
thuggery and violence which not
surprisingly you know puts a lot of
people off the danger is that somebody
will arise who is charismatic persuasive
articulates the views and interests of
lost people very effectively but who
doesn't have the kind of baggage that
people like Tommy Robinson or the
football
or whatever they call themselves have
the lads Alliance well would you say the
danger but if someone came along for you
you know people we get a lot of [ __ ]
actually for criticizing Thomas Robinson
ourselves ya know but you we but the
issue with him is I've listened to his
Oxford Union talk he explains a lot of
things quite articularly very well but
it's the association with violence and
thuggery as you say that for us is a
problem a lot of people want us to
interview him and we're like well he
does say some things that are
interesting and there are valid but that
Association is a problem for us right
but what if someone was to come along
and articulate the views and the needs
and the interests of working-class
people up and down this country who was
not violent who wasn't coming from that
background what's wrong with that uh
actually I don't think there is
something wrong with that I mean I think
what he said it was everyone okay I'm
the practically me rephrase present or
expanded slightly I think it is very
dangerous to have a significant bloc of
voters whose views concerns interests
are not being articulated that's very
dangerous
and one of the problems I think we've
had in democratic politics in most
developed countries over the last thirty
years is the narrowing of the range of
concerns and interests are represented
basically if you're a university
graduate and have a certain set of views
and you're working in certain areas of
the economy things are pretty good your
views are being discussed but for a lot
of other people it's not the case that's
very dangerous now the question is given
that what form does the politics that
represents those unrepresented currently
unrepresented interests take save you
like in the past
working-class interests are not
represented at the end of the 19th
century so there were two different
routes that their representation talked
one was too for them to be represented
by radical but democratic parties like
the Labour Party parties that you know
were not prepared to subvert civil
liberties were committed to preserving
the main institutions of the democratic
political process and the like the other
routes in say France for example was to
go and vote for the Communist Party a
Revolutionary Party that freak mildly
was not interested in maintaining
democratic
or liberal right so when we are talking
about an unrepresented working class or
working class that feels itself to be
unrepresented which maps the same thing
the question is then what kind of
politics comes along to express it if
it's the kind of politics which does
articulate their concerns and interests
but combines that with the kind of
radical revolutionary rhetoric or a
commitment to violence and the
destruction of their political opponents
that's extremely dangerous on the other
hand if it is the kind of politics which
says look here we have a set of views
and concerns that are not being taken
seriously we think they should be taken
seriously but does so within what you
might call the rules of the democratic
system that can't help but be a good
thing because it means that the people
who disagree with those of you whose all
have queries about them will at least
have to take them seriously and engage
with them this is the thing what can I
just say now we've been talking about
this political figure maybe it's me
because I'm not oh because I'm not as I
favored politics as everyone but we're
talking about this figure who has led a
movement that is a little bit
revolutionary addresses working-class
people's views it's Nigel Faraj isn't it
that's what I was about to some degree
yes absolutely
the only problem that I think Nigel
progenies of like the element of you
could be represented had was that he was
articulating me as concerns but he also
combined it with a kind of economic
position which personally I favor but
which was not going to I think appeal to
the audience he was also speaking for
because I think the crucial thing is
that you've got it if you think of there
being a four-way block four quadrants
really you've if the vertical axis up
here is this whole question of identity
that we're talking about the other axis
is how you feel about economics still
and so you've got on the one hand down
here a block of voters largely
working-class not entirely who are both
left-wing and economics and nationalist
or culturally traditionalist over here
you have bloc of voters who share the
cultural traditionalism but through a
much more free market or less
because left-of-center in economics now
up here on the other hand you've got on
the one hand the kind of people that the
independent group are appealing to
liberal Cosmopolitan's broadly free
marking very globalist and up here
you've got the far left you've got
momentum in the greens now the problem
is that I think Nigel Farrar just down
in this quadrant and his economic view
he's views on things like national
identity opposition to the EU they
appeal to those working-class voters
over here but his economic views did not
the big gap in the market if you will
he's for a party that is left of center
and economics but traditionally
nationalists what I would call a
national collectivist party this is what
the front of Nacional in France is
that's what marrying the pen is turning
into and I think that that's the kind of
big gap in the market if you will it's
like a left-wing Nigel for us exactly
yeah something like that and isn't that
what the Labour Party used to be indeed
up until but it hasn't been that for a
long time because I think what happened
was up from the nineteen or was early as
the 1960s perhaps certainly from the
nineteen eighties on once the Labour
Party became much less of a working
class party in terms of its leadership
anyway and much more dominated by
middle-class professionals who tended to
emphasize the social aspect of the
Labour Party's agenda rather than the
economic aspect and do you think a lot
of this comes from politicians who are
career politicians and their detachment
from everyday people and their issues
and the travails that they have in the
difficulties that they face to some
degree but I think that's a phenomenon
really over the last 15 no more than 20
years career politicians of that kind
the political classes I referred to
earlier I think what what you've got
with our MPs are in a better position
actually than MP or politicians in many
other countries because they represent
particular geographical constituencies
and because every week they have to go
and do surgeries and they actually come
into contact with voters on a much more
direct basis I think than politicians in
say France or Germany or Italy to so
that there's a there's a constant of
feedback mechanism there the problem is
though that to get a nomination to
advance within the party machinery to
get to the point where you get a
winnable
seeds you have to become one of these
professional politicians didn't used to
be the case there used to be lots of
ways in which you could get into
politics you could do it through being
in the law or business particularly the
Conservative Party you could do it
through being a trade union official or
activists in the labour party and both
parties took people from the military
and other professions that's no longer
the case you can only become an MP by
going through a very strictly structured
career route which involves having no
proper job what most people regard as a
proper job going to a very limited
number of academic institutions during
your academic career and basically
studying a pretty limited range of
topics the number of people who've done
PPE at Oxford or in Parliament is
remarkable and the result is therefore
an extremely narrow basis now having
then got into Parliament that process I
described means they then made to
realise that maybe the world they've
been working in for seven nine ten years
or so is not the whole of the world but
the problem is that's what they are and
so I think yes that is a problem
[Music]
do you think given that you've talked
about the fact that we're gonna get
possibly a few hung Parliament's and
that lack of decisiveness that we we
crave from the first-past-the-post
system do you think we need PR do you
think we need proportional
representation is it I think I think I I
would support some kinds of PR but not
others basically I would be totally
against any kind of proportion
representation that relies on a list
system because that would give even more
part power to party bureaucracies anyone
who's not familiar with that you just
break it down okay
ain't many countries like the
Netherlands for example or Israel which
is the most extreme case you just vote
for a party and the party has a list of
candidates and depending on let's say
that the party wins 10 percent of the
vote you go down its list until you
reach the number of people who make 10
percent of the legislature and they're
the monsters become MPs that means that
what determines whether you get into the
legislature is how high you are on the
list so that gives you enormous power to
the party managers and I don't approve
that at all uh I would strongly support
the Irish system which is where you have
a multi-member seat to seat with 3 to 5
MPs
which to often correspond to the local
government unit and you basically then
rank the candidates in order of
preference and the good thing there is
that you feel the voter you can give
first preference vote to somebody from
one party but a second preference pokes
some do you like from a different party
and also you vote within the party that
you support as well as between parties
so if you are a remain a conservative in
that system you can vote only for people
like Ana silvery converse Eve you're a
lever conservative you can make sure
that Jacob Riis more gets your number
one vote and you never give a vote to
you know Heidi Allen so I wait like that
system failing that the other the only
other kind of PR system I would support
is the German system where you have
single member seats but then there's a
top-up this is what they use in the
Scottish Parliament is wrong and Steve
we're gonna go back to Brick's briefly
because we are in to use a term hurtling
out or crashing out Israel I mean is
that a bad thing is it a good thing
and where do you stand on bricks it
because I've got no idea anymore well I
was actually on the fence in terms of
breaks it until really quite late on in
the referendum campaign it was only
about a week before the vote that I
decided I was going to vote leave and I
did so with the firm opinion that both
of the campaign's were doing their best
to get me to vote for the other side
they were so utterly useless in terms of
the quality of their argumentation and I
decided to put leave for two reasons one
is because I think that not being in the
EU will open up the range of options for
British policy makers and the British
electorate right now there's a whole
range of particular policy positions
some good some bad that you just can't
follow because they violate EU rules and
regulations so a kind of radical
free-market policies not possible but
also a radical socialist policy isn't
possible which is why I'm quite
convinced Jeremy Corbyn voted leave by
the way pretty much yeah so that's one
reason the other reason is I think that
I strongly suspect that the EU will not
be around in its current form in five
years it may well have collapsed
altogether because it has fundamental
design flaws which were acts of hubris
that the European politicians engaged in
the Maastricht conference obviously the
Euro which pretty much every economists
on the planet told them was a total
disaster but also I think the whole idea
of an EU common EU citizenship I think
that was an act of hubris because there
is no European demos people still think
of themselves as French German Italian
Dutch and Spanish not European so I
think that if the hotels are you know
burning better to get out before the
ceiling comes in it smiley you don't
think crashing out without it we both
voted remain by the way because we're
good there we go he always does that
joke we always get a ton of hate for us
online so now he's become a catchphrase
yeah yeah but we both might remain but
do you not think this idea of crashing
out without a deal is going to be
horrific everyone's gonna die we're all
gonna be eating rats alright no the word
crashing the term crashing out is
actually a loaded propagandist term what
that actually
is that we will legally leave and we
will then revert to trading with the EU
on World Trade Organization rules that's
what their actual legal situation will
be now I'm not saying it will be
painless actually there will be
significant disruption if we leave
without worked out trade deal if we go
to trading on WTO rules the reason is
that what we have is a lot of
transnational supply chains particularly
for manufacturing but for other sectors
as well and those supply chains will be
significantly disrupted in the short
term through things like customs checks
and controls and because so much
production is done an adjusting time
basis what that means is that things
could be delayed by say two or three
hours and believe it or not that
actually can disrupt the entire
production process because everything's
done adjusting time basis however I
think that would be sorted out in less
than a year there will be a whole slew
specific agreements made which would
sort our particular problems like for
example aircraft not being allowed to
take off from British airports don't fly
over European airspace I think that will
be sorted out very very quickly for
example so I think that yes there is
disruption for leaving without a worked
out trade deal in place and reverting to
WTO rules but the disruption is not
going to be the kind of catastrophic end
of the world that we're being told it
will be by a lot of the press that is
quite simply scare tactics
quite often deliberately designed to
panic the public but having I fear
actually for them the exact opposite
effect everyone thinking my god not
another scare story and they're actually
ignoring what might be genuine problems
in some cases but also it's a case of
taking a hypothetical worst-case
scenario and assuming that because this
might happen therefore it has to happen
and so you will get those reports saying
Oh companies have done contingency
planning for running out of food which
all things like that so the implication
is therefore this is what's going to
happen that's wrong contingencies are
things that might happen not necessarily
things are going to happen or even have
a probability of happening
and any company in its right mind with
responsible directors and managers is
going to plan for contingencies that's
what you always do you always plan for
worst-case scenarios and things going
completely you know pear-shaped there
you would be irresponsible not to do it
but that doesn't mean that the
probability of things going to active
pear-shaped is actually as high as
people often think it is much less a
certainty that some of the pressure
ports would have you believe and every
time I go on my facebook I just see a
list of companies are believing it's
going to be the end of trade as we know
it Britain is going to become you know
yeah is it realistic that we're gonna
lose a lot of trade to the EU no there
are two things that are going on there
what three things actually one is that
quite a lot of this is changes that
would have happened anyway so Honda
shutting down a factory in Swindon for
example that's something that would have
happened in any event Honda is basically
relocating all its production back to
Japan they've shut down a factory in
Turkey as well
and Turkey as a trade deal with the EU
so some of this is stuff that would have
happened anyway and it's now just a
convenient excuse to say oh it's because
of brakes is sometimes there will be
changes because there may be for example
that if you have one of those supply
chains you'll relocate part of what goes
on the UK over to Europe because it will
then become less costly because you
won't incur perhaps customs charges so
there is some of that going on as well
on the other hand what you've also got
is trade just going on as it did before
and I think that is actually going to be
the bulk of what you see simply because
making big changes like that is very
costly and people are not going to do
that if they can possibly avoid it plus
the EU exports are very large amount to
us we are we have been running a very
large trade deficit with the EU
basically with Germany for most of the
last 20 years and it's been getting
worse and worse in the sense we are
selling less and less to the EU the
Germans in particular are selling more
and more to us conversely our exports to
the world outside the EU are steadily
growing both in absolute terms and as a
proportion of total British trade and
GDP over the last ten years so
we are already less integrated with the
rest of Europe than most other EU
countries are and for that reason I
think the impact on the British economy
is not going to be as big as most people
imagine are we gonna have a second
referendum no absolutely you know I
would put strong money on that I'd give
you you know really long odds against
the second referendum because there's a
clear and overwhelming majority against
the environment and do you think Theresa
May is gonna what what was going to
happen do you think with the
Conservative Party because they is
interesting because labour in crisis and
we talk about labour a lot but we really
haven't mentioned the Tories they are
also in crisis they the problem that
vote the problem at the moment is that
Therese may wants to put through brac
said and she wants to do that purely
relying upon conservative and DUP votes
she knows that if she puts through a
deal which involves making a deal with
the Labour Party because of the terms
that Labour MPs were insist on which
involves being in the customs union it
would provoke an enormous split in her
own party basically if she reached out
to Jeremy Corbyn or beyond him labour
backbenchers and she made a deal
probably Norway plus as it's often
called going in the European Economic
Area remaining in the free free-trade
area then about all of the ERG about a
third of the party would walk out they
would effectively stand on their own
platform as a separate party and all
that name I suspect they would keep the
conservative label but they would
effectively be a new party she obviously
wants to avoid that almost any cost the
problem is it's not easy to see how she
can come up with any kind of deal that
will command the support of enough Tory
MPs and other MPs to get through
Parliament so she's in a very tricky
position so the Tory party is facing a
really serious division just like the
Labour Party is now Jeremy Corbyn on the
other hand he also wants to resume to
put through a brexit deal with only Tory
votes because he wants prexy to happen
but he wants the Conservative Party to
take like the blame for it and so he
thinks that then he can say well okay
we've left now now's the time for a
radical socialist policy to deal with
the problems the Tories have left us
with and let's forget about wreck [ __ ]
and get on with electing a Labour
government and meanwhile blame the
Conservatives for any kind of you know
bad news that does happen in the
aftermath but the problem is the kind of
mirror image of trees amazed which is a
he's got a block of MPs as we can see
cuz they're leaving now who are just
totally against that because they're
totally anti leaving but he's also got a
lot of MPs who if the choice is between
making a deal with Theresa May and
leaving without a deal they'd rather
make a deal with trees of Maine now it's
an interesting question what will happen
in Parliament and next month it may be
that we actually see the coming together
of a coalition of MPs beyond the party
leadership who will support something
like Norway plus now whether the EU
would then agree to that is another
matter I suspect not because quite
reasonably they've said that you can't
be in the single market and the tariff
union unless you also accept free
movement of labour quite reasonably
they're saying you can't cherry pick one
part of the deal and you know leave
their cell and I think there's no no way
most Conservative MPs would support that
on the other hand you never know the EU
also doesn't want Britain to leave from
WTO terms that we very disruptive for
them so they might well actually go
along with some kind of tweaks normal
deal but the question is whether or not
enough MPs are prepared at the last
minute to break their party whip to form
a cross party coalition oh I was talking
to someone involved in politics who said
that the EU and notorious are making
last-minute deals do you think we're
gonna get a deal at the 24th hour yes
probably I mean I think what the the
typical thing that happens is that you
get lots and lots of photographs of
tired and maybe slightly intoxicated the
EU figures staggering out of luxury
hotels at 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning
after something they've pulled an
all-nighter of like crash negotiations I
suspect something on that may happen the
only reason why it might well not happen
is that the issue of the Irish border is
particularly intractable and difficult
and it's not easy to see how it's even
possible for a deal to be made that will
actually command a majority in
parliament
well you know it's
sometimes when they only party not in
crisis of the Lib Dems yeah it's funny
times well I was listening to the radio
and maybe it was news night last night
and there was a remain a conservative
talking about how if we leave under WTO
rules he will leave the party this is
very true I think I think it resumes in
an extremely difficult position just
like Jeremy Corbyn is on the one hand if
she makes a deal the only way she can
get a deal through Parliament is to make
a deal with a lot of Labour MPs if she
does that the ERG and the Tory brexit
ears will effectively leave the party
Eve on the other hand she doesn't do
that given that there's no majority for
any deal she's got in Parliament that
means we would even WTO deals we would
have a no deal exit and at that point a
whole lot of people like Dominic grieve
and burr Rudd David Gork how about half
the cabinet and a big chunk of the party
would leave the party then and go over
to join the trade so she's she's
basically it's like in Persian mythology
when you die you have to go across a
bridge and the bridge gets narrower and
narrower as you walk across it and if
you're virtuous you make it to the other
side but if you're not you just fall off
and there's a bunch of crocodiles down
there to tell you apart and that's
pretty much more seizing the options are
getting narrower all the time and Jeremy
Corbyn is in a similarly very difficult
position do you know the one thing that
I'm going to take away for this
interview is and I hope you do as well
is if you've got ambitions to go into
politics don't become the leader of a
major political party
it's just what if I need to sing with
Corbin though is that this this guy came
to lead the Labour Party under this aura
of being principled and honest and
speaking truth to power and saying it
like it is and as you say he probably
voted leave and isn't admitting it he's
hedging his bets he's trying to get the
Conservatives to put through break sir
which is what he wants to happen under
the guise that he doesn't want it to
happen and it kind of puts into question
his whole status as this honest truth
speaking garden well I the point is he's
doing his job
I mean his job is to hold the Labour
Party's electoral Cole
together and it possible to use that
electrical coalition to gain power and
have a Labour government now everything
he does make sense in that light if he
comes out and says well actually I think
we know we should leave the EU because
that would make a more radical economy
policy possible which is all certainly
his view he's come pretty close to
saying that of course a huge chunk of
the Labour Party's MPs and his
membership would total fit so he
wouldn't win however on the other hand
if he comes out ardently for Pro remain
as people that Polly Tory in The
Guardian wants him to do and campaigns
to stay and I have a referendum then he
would lose a whole ton of seats in the
north of England and a whole bunch of
working-class voters to the
Conservatives or even a Renasant UK so
he can't do that so he's basically doing
what he has to do to do his job and
that's what politicians job is about the
idea that you can just say whatever you
like in politics is extremely naive
anyone who's actually gone into politics
should realise there's no point in being
in politics if you don't actually get
into power
oh so obviously you have principles you
don't compromise them totally but at the
same time you can't simply say openly
what you think all the time you have to
do things that will keep together the
electoral coalition you need to win
power I think that's a great place to
end it really and the way we learned
every interview is always the same it's
the same question Stephen what's the one
thing that we're not talking about as a
society or maybe in politics that we
really need to be talking about what a
terrible idea meritocracy is everybody
at the moment seems to think that
meritocracy is a great idea it's the way
to go it's one of those unexamined
beliefs that nobody really questions or
challenges I think it's one of the worst
ideas ever and it has destroyed
education in this country and I think a
lot of the argument we have over
education at both higher education level
and school level is really beside the
point because the real problem the thing
that is destroying education as an
activity is that we use formal education
as the way to decide
who gets high paid high status jobs and
this has had so many bad consequences I
hardly know where to start from the kind
of arms race between pushy parents to
get their kids into the right school and
then beyond that the right College to
the way that higher education has become
almost entirely about getting
certifications which are supposed to
give you a chance of a high paid high
state's job but increasingly not so
because of overproduction of graduates
basically for the number of graduate
positions available and so I think
that's a really bad idea but it has not
been subject to any kind of serious
criticism hold on so just just for
clarification yeah when I think of
meritocracy I think of the best person
for the job gets the job the the most
intelligent capable skilled whatever
gets the position gets the promotion
gets the advancement yeah right that is
that is not who would be against that
but thank you apparently no no but
that's not what that's not actually is
yeah there are two ther are two sort of
other aspects to meritocracy one is the
idea the way you determined who the best
person for the job is is by formal
academic qualifications that's highly
questionable to put it mildly but the
really deep problem is that the under
unexamined an implicit assumption is
that certain kinds of work certain kinds
of job are better more meritorious more
valuable more worthwhile than others and
what you do not want to do at any cost
is to be doing a job that is not
meritorious worthwhile valuable and high
status and I think that is an outrageous
idea and wrong on so many levels that I
don't know where to start my view very
strong view is that all kinds of work
have equal dignity and are equally
valuable that has mean they're going to
be paid the same for economic reasons
they won't be but it does mean that all
kinds of work should attract equal
social status and the idea that some
kinds of work should have a higher
social status and you then allocate them
through this supposedly meritocratic
system of examinations and certificate
I think that's a disgraceful idea well
we will leave it there dr. Stephen Davis
thank you very much for coming on you're
on Twitter at its big 365 Steve 3 we'll
put that in the video as always follow
us I had trigger pod and all the social
media subscribe to the YouTube channel
click that bell next to subscribe button
and give us a review on iTunes thank you
very much and we will see you very soon
take care guys thank you very much and
thanks for watching bye bye
[Music]